alright
returning officer the election remember
record of consistently do hereby give
notice
selection is fun
Chris Carmichael the Green Party
61
drizzle
Chris Davis
welsh Conservative Party
16,000
53
Matthew Matthew dorrance Welsh Labour
5,000
Freddie grieves flied camry the party of
Wales 1000
darn thomas UK Independence Party 3330
Roger q Williams flesh intervention
351
and I do and I do hereby declare that
the said Chris Davis is duly elected
member for the sentence
we be like
right
dis Davis encasing pies
victory
30 beats by dre
UK dependence
kim williams
I could eat
we've joined in the dust pan with a
dividend increase Davis with a young
I sheriff returning officer ladies and
gentlemen first of all aware thank you
so for looking after the accounts and
deputy returning officer for looking
after the election today the team here
in cloud rendered and also throughout
the constituency as usual in powers
worked exceedingly hard I'm sure and all
the candidates as well as myself would
like to thank you for all the hard work
that you've done and I'd also like to
thank the police will be with us today
that we won't need it but it's delighted
to have you with us in wreck and Radner
sure we have a very safe count on a very
safe election but thank you for being
with us today and ladies and gentlemen
to be declared the new
Parliament for record radishes
exceedingly big honor to have such a
majority is an amazing position to be in
and I'm so grateful to the people who
brag around the ship but their trusted
me today and I can assure you that I
will be doing everything possible over
the next five years to deliver for you
to return that trusting you
taking over the mantle
would like to thank you sincerely and
most genuinely
great job of the last 14 years I may not
always be his politics I'm always
believed that gorgeous done what he's
done
I sincerely with the people the great
interests of the people regular
join me in thanking him giving his 14
years to this concision sake
i would also i'm sure you'd agree with
me wishing well also a penny well
outside of house of commons but i know
that he hasn't finished in perfectly
and I'm sure we see more project musica
but I also please thank my colleagues as
candidates they've all worked extremely
hard they put up excellent campaigns we
have an interesting debated hustings but
I'm grateful for them for the way that
they have concluded their campaigns
they've done exceedingly well and I wish
the world in few years in politics or
whatever they choose to do preferably
outside a record rather [ __ ] but good
luck to you
on a very personal basis I would like to
thank my team and my
paying manager in hurst my
cheering team
believe mr. chairman to campaign a good
and Williams charity Association all my
volunteers several have come into the
back of the room now it's been a real
pleasure
it's been a real pleasure to work with
it's been a massive campaign
two years to try and win the seat
mersin from north south east and west in
the considerin see and its really has
been a team effort I'm so grateful
in person later on
finally I'd like to thank my family
without too
done this
the rifle is
it's been a team effort so
so thank you all very very much it's
going to be a very good morning for us
certainly the Conservative Party person
Davis I've sold
our job to start tomorrow and
allow me a couple of hours off to enjoy
myself after this and celebrate but
thank you very much that's what people
you made somebody exceedingly proud
that's you